happy Halloween everyone yes Halloween
means we got to see all of our favorite
celebs in costume here's our round-up
the best amber rose and Val Chmerkovskiy
fueled dating rumors with these ski
shots the source tells ET their
just-good-friends Amber's bestie blac
Chyna channeled the purge with her boo
Rob Kardashian his sister Kourtney
rocked this sexy spider man or woman
look while their mom Kris Jenner shut it
down as Alice in Wonderland ok when
Stephanie went to Wonderland to but has
a zombie and Taylor Swift's squad went
all out in a variety of looks turns out
Taylor's at Deadpool costume was the
real deal come up Ryan Reynolds of
course there were a ton of kiddos out
including jenna dewan and Channing
Tatum's little girl Everly the whole
family got into the spirit as two
beauties and one be this year ah it's
going to be amazing I'm going to kill it
this year and kill it she did kim
zolciak biermann's twins were absolutely
adorable as danny and sandy from grease
Neil Patrick Harris is twins weren't too
shabby either as Marilyn Monroe and
James Dean I got that sunshine in my
pocket
that gets on my feet meanwhile Justin
Timberlake got in a little promo for
trolls he Jessica Biel and their son
Silas all went as characters from his
new movie The Rock rocked out as a
Pikachu to impress his baby girl with
daddy stew and Beyonce jay-z and Blue
Ivy totally stole our hearts with their
Harvey and Ken costumes ice-t and Coco
on the other hand enjoyed a kid-free
night out at Heidi Klum's annual bash
with Coco narrowly avoiding a wardrobe
malfunction in her referee costume while
Amber Heard made a rare public
appearance in a masquerade mask and REO
winter went seductive in this grease
goddess look your costume is pretty oh
it's not a costume I'm an elf Oh Kelly
Clarkson went for laughs as buddy the
elf while Lena Dunham got political with
this grabbed her by the Hutt well you
know costume and the new girl cast took
on pop culture is a biggest show the
People vs oj simpson american crime
story and finally Barack and Michelle
Obama didn't dress up for their final
White House Halloween but they did it
get down to thriller
you